[Música]
con esa sensación que hace que te
brillen los ojos el corazón te lata más
rápido y la cabeza se te llene de sueños
y esperanza se llama magia y es la
sustancia de la que están hechas las
películas
imagínense cuando aparecieron los
primeros pines y la gente pudo disfrutar
por primera vez de una película esas
películas aunque eran en blanco y negro
y sin color y sin sonido les hacían
soñar les hacían imaginar cosas que
jamás habían visto les hacían creer que
todo era posible desde su nacimiento el
cine es uno de los medios con mayor
evolución tecnológica desde esas
primeras películas hasta hoy en día
donde podemos disfrutar de contenidos de
alta calidad en cualquier lugar y en
cualquier device
y sin embargo hace poco vi un documental
precioso cinema travelers cuenta la
historia de un de un camión destartalado
que lleva una tienda mágica aldeas
remotas de la india en esta tienda se
proyectan películas y hay gente que las
puede ver por primera vez
y cuando hubiese documental recordé
porque me enamoré del cine
y la cara de esa gente me recordó que la
misión de las películas es emocionarnos
es por eso que fue un de garay stories
en este momento esta gran revolución
tecnológica con la realidad virtual la
realidad aumentada es lo que lo que
queremos hacer desde garay stories es
asegurarnos que no sólo avanza la
tecnología sino los contenidos y que
esas experiencias así se proyecten en
pantallas o en hologramas lo que siguen
proyectando son sonrisas en sus caras
ilusión en sus ojos y que sigan creyendo
que todo es posible
es por eso que ayer estuvimos en la
universidad de galileo donde jóvenes de
este país muy talentosas porque hay
mucho talento en guatemala estuvieron
trabajando juntos en equipos de gente
que no se conocía de nada y les dimos un
reto en un día generar ideas que con
esas nuevas tecnologías y relacionadas
con el mundo del audiovisual pudieran
cambiar el mundo y mejorarlo y es para
mí un honor presentarnos el equipo
ganador beatbox
[Aplausos]
[Música]
gracias quiero comenzar con una pregunta
con el interrogante quién es de ustedes
se durmieron en clase de geografía o en
cualquier otra clase porque de verdad el
contenido era malo o era aburrido
sí misma ti no tenía la culpa verdad
y quienes creen que de verdad la
tecnología puede resolver la
problemática de la interacción que hoy
en día tenemos que la educación es a
veces aburrida y a veces compleja de
recibir quienes creen que la tecnología
puede cambiar eso nosotros gracias
nosotros creemos que sí y es por eso que
hoy con este grupo de compañeros a
través de la realidad aumentada y a
través de lo que es la interacción
creamos esta aplicación creamos esta
herramienta llamada beat books & books
les voy a dar un ejemplo de lo que hace
por ejemplo mi compañero alejandro será
el maestro de ellos dos beat books lo
que va a hacer es que alejandro le va a
entregar a ellos dos cada ficha esta
ficha por ejemplo aljandro llevará el
contenido de de geografía volcanes de
guatemala por ejemplo el volcán
acatenango toda la información estará
dentro de esta ficha lo que va a ser
alejandro es que les va dar una breve
introducción del volcán y luego el
alumno a través de su smartphone o
teléfono inteligente y una aplicación de
realidad
podrá ver todo acerca del volcán
acatenango pero eso no es todo por
ejemplo cada quien va a llevar una
historia diferente de un alpinista por
ejemplo contándole la experiencia y no
sólo eso sino que también toda la
información acerca del volcán acatenango
esto lo que va a hacer es que la
información va a llegar de una forma
interactiva y también la experiencia de
subir un volcán hacia las aulas o
colegios así también luego de esto
alejandro podrá preguntarles a ellos o
primero también podrá decirles bueno que
aprendieran nuestro ustedes dos
compartan se qué historia recibieron los
alumnos comparten su historia y luego él
podrá hacer un pequeño cuestionario o un
pequeño repaso de lo que aprendieron o
de lo que recibieron a través de las
historias que estos alpinistas le dieron
y todo el contenido acerca del volcán la
catedral como resolvemos la parte de
contenidos pues bueno nosotros ya somos
un equipo qué
desarrolladores publicistas diseñadores
y cineastas ya podemos generar los
internamente y además podemos invitar a
otros artistas a llenar nuestro
contenido luego de este contenido
podemos ofrecerles o ofrecerlo como
licencias a los establecimientos
educativos para que ellos se lo den a
los maestros y estos maestros a través
de los beat books puedan llenarlos
una y otra y otra vez para apoyarse en
el contenido que necesitan ya sea
matemáticas ciencias sociales para que
así fomentar lo que es la interacción
entre el alumno y recibir mejor la
educación
luego de esto y en conclusión nosotros
creemos que de verdad la innovación y la
educación pueden estar en esta ficha
pero sabemos que la educación es
muchísimo más importante que el oro y la
plata por eso facebook los invitamos a
que todos juntos invirtamos en el futuro
de la educación gracias muchas gracias
[Música]